when I was in my first trip in the
Middle East I was at the headquarters of
the fourth ID the day three men got lost
three men lost their lives on patrol and
they came back and informed the fourth
ID major Hammond I think it was his name
at the time
he addressed the room and it was one of
the most powerful five minutes of my
watching him address his soldiers
uh I'd never seen I never felt you could
feel it right I mean it's just that
sense of leader some people were just
born to lead and this guy clearly had
everything about him was lit that was
Darren Dalton the best leader of people
in any venue I've ever been around in
one way and what never said the wrong
thing at the wrong time and always said
the right thing at the right time wow
and he knew his Twitter and this is what
a leader is Right a leader is the person
who puts his position in the best people
in the best position to succeed I don't
care what you do for a living right you
understand your roster you understand
who's what strengths are and what
weaknesses are and you put those people
accordingly Darren knew us to the point
where Philadelphia northeast media could
be a little bit of an animal right you
can play the game and then you have to
play the media game afterwards Darren
I'll give you a quick example middle of
the Season I'm struggling having the
worst month of my career and it's all
self-inflicted and we just get I I pitch
a game in St Louis and I give up like
505 runs in two innings it was it was
horrific
and it's 190 degrees out on the turf
there and after the game
we had another picture on our staff who
was really really good but but mentally
wasn't a strong guy Darren goes to the
media comes to Darren he says you know
he calls me out he said you know what
this guy's worried about all the wrong
stuff doing all it and just he's saying
this to the media over just burying me
and and the other guy he doesn't really
say much about but he hints that it's
more than one guy and the media comes
sprinting over to Philadelphia media
they're in love with this right they can
run over my locker and they lay out this
laundry list of things that Darren just
said about me and they look at me and
they're like
what do you got to say and I was like
he's right
he was and I okay I got called out for
some I had never had a problem listen as
a Christian the one thing I'm telling
you is I'm admitting to you that I'm far
from perfect so I don't have a problem
being wrong I have a problem being wrong
twice but I did I was like yeah he's
right and I knew what he was doing more
importantly so then stupid me says well
you know I'm this and that I'm not going
to lose the game the second half and I
didn't but the point was I was I was
really you're losing no no I was that
guy well you said this to who though
you're not going to lose again the media
you told him you're not gonna You're
Gonna Lose I did that a lot though
because well and but because a lot of it
sometimes nothing out there will put the
challenge to you that you put to
yourselves right and I'm okay with that
but by the way the the other picture we
won't talk about his name was he also
protecting him that's why he threw you
on exactly knew you could take it and he
couldn't exactly right and I don't know
if this Dynamic happens in the military
but I've had situations where
as a coach I want to find a player Oh
preferably my star listen I'm gonna
undress you in front of the team don't
take it personal I don't mean it to you
but if I can undress you in front of the
team then nobody's exempt right that you
always want that guy and I was I was
comfortable being stuck I was
comfortable being that guy yeah because
I knew who I was but was he a feared guy
or was he a respected guy Dalton so he
was he was a bad so would he push around
because he wasn't he was a big guy he
was not a in 22 years of professional
sports I never was on a team that got in
spring training fights we fought four
times that spring we cleared benches
with us we is who our team cleared
benches with other teams four times
because we finished in last year before
and we were like you guys aren't pushing
us around and we were big bunch of boys
yeah yeah John Kroc who was leading guy
right Dave Hollins who was the meanest
toughest player I ever played with in my
life Dave Holland Dave Hollins 17 this
guy has an operation broke his handmade
bone he's got a pin sticking out of his
thumb 17 days after the surgery he's
done the batter's box playing in a game
with a pin still sticking on its hand
who else who else was on that team
you're talking about these two badass
dudes Mitch Williams yeah 22 years of
playing baseball only Battle of pitching
only bad team I never had really only
about that's the only bad Mitch Williams
because he was kind of a loose cannon
pitcher right was it yeah he was what he
was he had uh the guys that it's it's
funny too because when I think back to
the most impactful guys in the clubhouse
setting and it's one of the Dynamics
that and I say this very Loosely I share
with
the military the barracks Police
Barracks the fire Barracks the sports
Clubhouse those are four places that the
real world couldn't function the things
that we say and do to each other in
those environments because I can say
anything I want about your mother but
nobody else can right in that
environment that is the definition of
locker room talk it it's the place where
my God I wish America was because where
you come from what color you are and who
you sleep with are totally irrelevant
can you turn a double play with runners
in scoring position okay as long as
you're not sleeping with my wife I don't
really care who you sleep with I don't
care who you worship or pray yeah those
things are irrelevant and so it's the
most
racially inclusive
Club you'll ever be in and the things
that are said in there if if the real
world knew they would probably stop
watching sports the things that we say
and do to each other in those
environments but it's how you de-stress
because we lose a game but we do it in
front of 50 000 people on TV in front of
hundreds of thousands when you lose in
that environment you lose a life so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]